you
my opponent is the one who lets go with
the Carroll Khan why not use the one who
guessed number eight all right so will
we have the yes we will so it's the
Carroll Khan exchange pan off Botvinnik
I've played this a lot its knight c6
it's one that could really go right into
an ending late night c6 Knight f3 Bishop
out and Queen b3 line grabbing on b7 but
I'm not gonna go that direction just
gonna go be more reserved here Bishop g5
Bishop e7 takes hmm one thing I need to
be a little bit concerned about is this
potential structural change c5 so hmm
could do a counter pin have an absolute
pin on the knight this is maybe regard
is a half pin but okay Kanan it moves
include Bishop here Bishop here takes
those are just some rough thoughts it's
just uh let's let's break the pin how
bad can that be right
come on you just developed and you broke
a pin you're doing beautiful things
simple simple and good hopefully
alrighty so what's your bite do develop
c5 hopefully not streams tonight don't
listen to the stream I can use stream
tactics if that happens it would not be
the first you know what I'm not gonna do
raise your hand if you know the answer
fill in the blank I'm not gonna take on
c4 until what move idle at move until
the Bishop Lopes I saved myself a move
and now we're working with an IQ p IQ p
scenario okay yeah that's the pawn
structure we're working with let's get
developed here um isolated queen pawns
so so what's what's the story here
what's going on the timer's continuing
to tick of course I'd really like to get
my knight here I'm wondering if knight
c6 is Bastyr or this what I have to be
fearful of that move maybe alright let's
do this one alright let's get there
right now what's the most important
square in this position d5 in four which
color white or black or both both white
needs to make sure they keep pressure on
this square and maybe threatened to be
playing d5 I don't know if castling was
most accurate I wonder if a3 would have
been best see this is this is now
kicking my knight away to a square that
I am pretty sure he wanted to go to so I
don't know that that was best more
common move to see would be a rope to
see one or rook to e1 but white is a
white he's continuing to be a pest
keeping pressure on d5 okay
playing with the purpose for sure and I
wonder if I could simply trade a little
bit it's usually not a bad idea to do
just that if you're fighting against an
isolated pawn so we do some dynamic
possibilities that white may very well
have this is the only problem I'm
needing to solve get him working still
looking to complete development White's
last move well now white white is fully
developed so I'm considering Knight
takes
and then b6 with Bishop b7 but I have
some some worry of some sacrifice on
this square as soon as I move my bishop
should I really be concerned about that
maybe I should be more concerned about
my time I definitely don't want to go
here kick the bishop away and then what
am I gonna do with this clown I should
probably take I don't want to allow a
ram structure either I don't want to
allow you know I still want to play
where it's where I have this square
vacant I want I want to have this square
open um I think here see here 95 Bishop
here Bishop takes pawn takes Queen takes
I move away Knight here you know maybe
maybe I'm gonna just have to be okay
with that my opponent would end up with
more points would end up with get a rook
in two pawns for the minor pieces okay
all right I'm actually fine with that I
really like having my bishop here wonder
if white should've still waited you know
I think this would be a move I would
want to do and maybe then take if
anything but my plan here is to still
finish development this is a potential
liability this is a hanging pawn
structure I think some some people get a
little bit more technical about it they
don't call it maybe hanging hanging pawn
structure until they're both on the
fourth-ranked but I tend to just kind of
view it as a hanging pawn structure as
is as it is right now whether it's like
this or both on the fourth ring so okay
I'm pointing right here I have the
bishop pair it's an open position when I
rip the lungs on this half open file or
about a minute off right here I have the
very common natural retreat to preserve
the bishop and still watch out for any
knight hops into my territory
so 94 instinctually I'm thinking about
Bishop e7 let's go there there's still
this move but I don't believe it's
really amounting to too too much I'm
really I'm gonna be fine with that
Queen the c7 is threatening the bishop I
could offer a queen exchange and I'm
almost always a fan of that I think it's
also one of the better moves in this
position maybe I could now think about
transferring over here and one day maybe
starting to get both my bishops on these
adjacent diagonals I've talked about
that before they function very well
adjacent diagonals those those bishops
so he's the last clown that needs to do
something
the last piece not working so we're
gonna miss you here and when the knight
moves are there any unprotected pieces
let's just make a move here I still just
want to get all my pieces working this
is weakening this diagonal let's get
this rook working first and maybe I want
to get in this pawn break well actually
yes because right now this bishop is
potentially vulnerable a5 is not long
off from coming and while I have to
watch out for this rook planting in my
territory if I do this now rook here is
a little bit of a bug however it drops
this pawn however I don't have a lot of
time hmm
I'm just gonna go here I just I really
just don't want to deal with the rook
rook to b5 move and now if I do this
there's Bishop here let's go here scare
the knight a little bit is he scared
Bishop here I go here and then after
Bishop takes I take here I don't want
this bishop to take and be on my queen I
was thinking Bishop here Queen here what
Bishop takes is then on my queen I want
to I would really be in favor
oops well was I going to say I really be
in favor of having both sets of minor
pieces off the board with the position
stripped like that let's go back and I
missing anything I think it should still
be alright let me finish that the major
piece ending alone okay this is
everything's crumbling now
my pick this is a time problem I imagine
what I was going to say again major
piece only position means that I'm still
the better side because of that I have
the better structure more pieces being
traded and then these guys are just
sitting targets all right now let's just
trade trade trade trade is the plan just
take out this night take out this pawn
yeah there's some some things that I
could be pointing out well I'll be end
up reiterating but uh as soon as we got
under a minute it's the the quality
certainly goes down for both of us
all right good game let's go back let's
flip see how things look from your
perspective so again this is the Carroll
Khan defense exchange variation and with
c4 we know call it a pan out bought
vinik attack there's Bishop g5 I believe
you have many choices here Bishop g5 9
f3 is pretty common c5 I don't know how
common is but I have seen that weave
before immediately going for structural
change but okay you went with this I
break it and I'm wondering if maybe even
now there's this move believe there's
there still would be one of the things
that I could say is you'll want to be on
the black side a bit careful about
deploying your queen night too early
because of this c5 move with Bishop to
b5 capturing on this c6 square is it
tends to be a favorable structure for
white I'm pretty sure with c5 Bishop
here taking out the knight the next pawn
break black would really like to get in
would be e5 but that becomes more
difficult to manage
you pretty much maybe a better way to
state it is that you want to be in a
position to meet c5 with b6 but if
you're making a capture on c6 you're not
going to be able to challenge the c5
pond the palm that's in your territory
as easily but we never even went down
that road did we and I'm not capturing
until the bishop moves that way save a
move you had to move twice before he's
on c4 and here instead of doing the more
natural castling move I think a3 might
be more accurate keeping my knight out
of this d5 square it's not so easy for
me to get to this square if you play a
three maybe that's better instead of
castles and now you're kicking me to a
square that I wanted to go to maybe
there's even something better at this
point maybe the Queen here immediately
consider that as it stood in the game
what did you do a3 and then the Queen
came here and then I took maybe an
immediate Queen to b3 would be a small
improvement G again just synched some
rough thoughts here and maybe at this
point you need to be posting up to this
'if I've Square this is quite common
moves I was pointing out some earlier
earlier here some fairly natural moves
for both sides okay a3 was one
suggestion but I was pointing out that
once you're a castle you could be
playing here up to e1 I pointed out his
his spot just these open or half open
files but also when we look at the minor
pieces this is a common follow up as
well for this King Knight once he's on
f3 that next square he looks to go to is
e5 and maybe even in some line c5 not
necessarily this night but the e5 and c5
squares tend to be good ones the e5
square is more difficult for black to
cover of course there's always b6 that
could kick away a minor piece but it's
not so easily
done over here with f6 weakens the
diagonal King position etc but this this
is maybe a good move to be running with
what I'm getting at right here instead
of instead of kicking my night maybe
even maybe even throwing the night in
there or at this point right here even
after the capture to play Knight e5
right now I think there's there's no I
think the I think I start to be better
since you're taking my night out and
that these these really start to be more
more so liability than anything else I'm
thinking Nike five and if I do this as I
was citing in the game to capture here
and go into a position in unbalanced
position where rook and rook and two
pawns versus two minor pieces I'm not
sure or if you're not going to go
forward with that still just play your
knight here and if Bishop here maybe you
maybe you make some more strengthening
moves like rook to e1 or up to d1
improve your position in that way and
maybe a little bit later that tactic
becomes all the more powerful like if my
rook wants to go elsewhere then like
Knight e5 Bishop here maybe you move
your up to e1 or up to d1 maybe maybe a
little bit later this tactic will be
powerful or some tactic immediately on
e6 so just some food for that I think
I'm quite comfortable here with the
bishop pair and having the rooks ideally
placed this diagonal is weak and then
we're just really down on time at this
point beyond repair so okay I'm not sure
really what more to add beyond that but
uh already good game
you